bienvenidos a la presentación de
graficando líneas empecemos
digamos que tengo la ecuación
i
igual a 2
x + 1 esto nos está dando una relación
entre xy por ejemplo cuando x es igual a
1 que es igual a 2 por uno más uno lleva
a ser igual a tres por lo que para cada
x en la que podamos pensar tendremos una
ley que le corresponde
así que hagamos eso si dijéramos que
haré una tabla aquí
x
hay que escribir unos números al azar
para x
si x fuera digamos menos 1 entonces ya
sería dos veces menos uno que es menos
dos más uno sería menos uno si x fuera
cero es fácil vamos a ver todos por cero
es cero más uno
si x fuera uno que sería dos por uno que
es dos más uno que da
si x fuera 2 y creo ya tienen la idea de
esto que sería 5 y podríamos seguir
porque hay un número infinito de x que
podríamos usar y por ende un valor
infinito de ellas pueden ver que en esta
pequeña tabla se muestran las relaciones
entre xy y lo que podemos hacer ahora es
de hecho graficar esos puntos en los
ejes coordinados entonces déjame ver si
puedo dibujar este algo de una manera
limpia estos son mis ejes
deja dibujó algunas divisiones a los
ejes
entonces este es
- 1 - 2 - 3 este es mi eje x
y aquí tenemos 1 2 3 y por acá es menos
1 - 2 - 3 este es el eje
entonces graphic hemos cada uno de los
puntos si tenemos el punto donde x es
menos uno y es menos uno así que x y
vamos a ir a lo largo del eje x tenemos
que x es igual a menos 1
y si es igual a menos 1 así que este
punto está justo aquí
este es el punto menos 1,21 hagamos otro
utilizando un color distinto
digamos que tenemos el punto 0 1
entonces si x es 0 que es aquí y es 1
así que este punto está justo aquí
hagamos uno más tenemos al punto 13 13 x
es 1 y tenemos que hoy es 3 entonces el
punto estaría justo aquí y podemos
seguir graficando pero creo que se
alcanza a ver que estos puntos están
formando una línea déjame dibujarla
la línea se ve algo como esto
la línea atraviesa a todos estos puntos
de hecho el punto 25 estaría por acá
arriba y cada punto para cada equis en
la que puedas pensar si tienes que x es
igual a no sé 3 billones 380 la ye
correspondiente también estará en esta
línea así que esta línea continúa
infinitamente eso representa todas las
posibles combinaciones de xy yes que van
a satisfacer esta ecuación
y por supuesto que x no tiene que ser
necesariamente números enteros y que
puede ser x puede ser p
es decir 3.14 15-9 que estaría por aquí
y yesería 21 así que todo valor de x
tiene su valor de g correspondiente
hagamos otro
si tengo la ecuación
es igual a menos 3
x +
entonces este es mi eje x
y este es mi eje
déjame poner unos valores aquí
x
i
entonces si x es menos uno menos uno por
menos tres es 35 es 8
si x 0 entonces 10 5 s es muy fácil si x
es 1
- 35 es 2
si x es 22 x menos 3 es menos 65 10
menos 1 y ahora graphic hemos los puntos
cuando x es menos 1 y sólo lo haré de
manera aproximada cuando x es menos uno
que es 8 positivo el punto estaría por
aquí
y hay todo un módulo en graficar
coordenadas si es que encuentran
graficar el parc ordenado o un poco
confuso
cuando x es 0 10 5 y estaría por aquí
cuando x es 1 10/2 así que está acá
cuando x es 2 10 1 pueden ver que y yo
le aproxime pero si lo hubiera hecho en
papel milimétrico podrían ver que la
línea atraviesa perfectamente a todos
los puntos
cada punto que satisface esta ecuación
cae sobre esta línea y algo interesante
de esto que me gustaría resaltar es que
la pendiente de la línea es descendente
va de la izquierda arriba a la derecha
abajo mientras que la línea que
dibujamos antes iba de la izquierda
abajo a la derecha arriba hay algo en
esta ecuación que se ve un poco
diferente a la anterior
les daré una pista este número el 3
negativo
podemos decir que es el coeficiente de x
este determina si la pendiente aumenta o
si disminuye
te dice también que tan empinada está la
línea y aquí menos 3 es la pendiente por
lo que y haré otro módulo de solo la
pendiente pero
este número de aquí es llamado ordenada
al origen y está te dice dónde va a
interpretar la línea al eje y en este
caso se inter seco en 0.5
hagamos una más
vamos a hacerlo rápido
es igual a un medio
de x
entonces hagamos nuestra tabla
x
y
y solo necesitamos dos puntos para
graficar una línea entonces digamos que
x es igual a cero eso es fácil que es
igual a 2 y si x es igual a 2 entonces
es igual a 3 graphic hemos antes
habíamos evaluado 3 o 4 puntos pero eso
sólo fue para que lo entendieran mejor
pero solo necesitamos dos puntos para
una línea así que es 0,12 está aquí y
2,3 está aquí de tal manera que la línea
se va a ver algo así
no tenemos aquí que otra vez tenemos una
pendiente ascendente y esto es porque un
medio es positivo pero no nos estamos
moviendo tan rápido que cuando teníamos
2x ya igualados x se inclina algo así
incrementa mucho mucho mucho más rápido
en este último ejemplo la ordenada al
origen está en 0 2 está justo aquí
así que si alguna vez quieres graficar
una línea es muy sencillo solo tienes
que evaluar dos puntos en el siguiente
módulo les mostraré un poco más sobre
pendientes y sobre la ordenada al origen
por lo que ya no tendrán que utilizar
esto pero creo que de esta manera
pudieron sentir intuitivamente en lo que
es la gráfica de una línea espero se
hayan divertido